WIL WILLIS: Up
first, the kill test.
Doug.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: Blade smiths,
what kind of lethal damage
will a weapon like the
Russian pioneer sword do?
Well, to find that out,
we will take your sword
and deliver slashes and
thrusts on this deer carcass.
Mark, you're up first.
You ready?
MARK: Yeah.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
MARK: I think my sword is
going to hold up to the deer.
I'm not really
intimidated by it.
It's not the first
deer I've seen hanging.
[music playing]
[cutting sounds]
DOUG MARCAIDA: OK
Mark, let's talk
about your weapon right here.
It's a little bit
on the heavier side.
But you know what?
It felt very good
cutting each time.
Cutting through the spine
and lacerating through.
Overall your weapon will kill.
MARK: Thank you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Good job.
Nicholas, your turn.
You ready?
NICHOLAS: I'm ready.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
NICHOLAS: I'm nervous
going into this test.
My stomach is
absolutely lurching.
Plus Mark's blade performed
pretty well, so that's
certainly adding to my anxiety.
[music playing]
[cutting sounds]
Oh, [bleep].
DOUG MARCAIDA: Well Nicholas,
that was a lot of fun.
The handle is on
the smaller side.
When he held onto it, you
could feel the ridges,
so that's good.
You can tell where the edge is.
Just a concern that
it might be an issue
when you're moving it around.
Your tip penetrated easily
all the way through.
The edges cut right
through the ribs,
right through the spine, all the
way through this deer carcass.
Overall your weapon will kill.
NICHOLAS: Thank you.
J NEILSON: Smiths, welcome
to our strength test.
Now I think pioneer,
I think horses.
So I'm going to take your
Russian pioneer swords
and smash them into
these horse skulls.
I'm not too concerned what
your swords do to the skulls,
I want to see what the skulls
are going to do to your swords.
Mark, you're up first.
You ready?
MARK: Yeah.
J NEILSON: Let's do it.
[music playing]
[skull breaking]
Well Mark, that first couple
swings it twisted a little bit.
You did get some
chipping on the edge
here, right in that sweet spot.
Otherwise, everything
is still tight.
It felt good.
Good job.
MARK: Thank you.
J NEILSON: Nicholas,
what are you thinking?
NICHOLAS: A little nervous.
J NEILSON: That's all right,
we're going to do it anyways.
NICHOLAS: Oh, I know.
I wouldn't expect anything less.
J NEILSON: Cool.
NICHOLAS: I'm especially
nervous about the strength test
because I had to
rush my heat treat.
This is going to be a make or
break moment for this thing.
[music playing]
[skull breaking]
J NEILSON: Nicholas, this
was difficult to control.
It's very forward heavy.
You've got chipping on the
edge here in a couple spots.
The real killer for me though,
was the seam in your handle,
this right here is sharp.
Most of your control is
in these three fingers
and these two are
getting cut into.
So the handle is a problem.
WIL WILLIS: Mark,
Nicholas, both of you
have done an incredible
amount of work
to get to where
you are right now.
But in this competition
there can only
be one Forged in Fire champion.
[music playing]
Mark, congratulations.
You are our new Forged
in Fire champion.
Nicholas, unfortunately your
weapon didn't make the cut.
J NEILSON: Nicholas,
despite taking damage,
both your weapons
performed pretty equally.
But at the end of the day, we
all agreed that handle just
hurts to use.
And that's why we're
sending you home.
NICHOLAS: I understand.
WIL WILLIS: Nicholas,
please surrender your blade.
NICHOLAS: This is more or
less what I was expecting.
Things were just so rushed
and chaotic at the end there,
you know, something had to give.
And if it's a little
sharp spot on the handle
and that's made the
difference, I'm OK with that.
I still chopped a deer
in half, and I don't
think everybody can say that.